hey everyone it's Mike here from order
flows and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for today's video
we're going to be talking about sort of
concept of trap Traders how to identify
them and you know some of the ways I
think people uh misidentify them
and before I jump in you know if you've
been enjoying my videos and learning
from them be sure to subscribe to the
channel click the notification Bell so
you don't miss any new upload and if you
find today's video helpful be sure to
hit the like button for me and leave
some comments in the section below you
know I love hearing your feedback your
support really does go a long way in
helping me create more videos so let's
go ahead and get started with today's
topic all right let's get into it so the
concept of trap Traders what are trap
Traders well basically they're traders
that are long and wrong or short in the
hole right these people sold at the low
of a move or bought the high of a move
right there they're basically looking
for a breakout that never materialized
now
when I see a lot of people talking about
trap Traders you know stock Traders I
call them stock Traders you know that's
the term that I picked up when I was in
Singapore
um you know people being stuck in a bad
position
um but to me it's the same thing and you
know a lot of people they'll look at a
chart like this is a bar chart and say
oh there's trap Traders up here or trap
Traders down here or trap Traders here
or trap Traders here they'll just look
for you know a more a little bit of a
recent breakout that failed and just
automatically assume that it's uh
trap Traders right and then they'll say
all the trainers are trapped well you're
just guessing right I mean really what
you want to be looking at is the volume
and again it's semantics I mean you know
if you want to call you know the people
up here trap traders of course you can
right because obviously people are
buying up here or not you know it's just
one of those things as a Trader and
someone that watches order flow you know
seeing the volume that goes through
there's a big difference between uh
normal
a volume of trade or normal Market
facilitating trade and actual trap
Traders okay but again you know I'm not
going to say oh you can't say there's no
trap Traders here because obviously
someone is selling it down in here and
reverse it sort of the problem that I I
get is you know a problem but rather the
thing that sort of makes my
hair on my arms Rise um is because
people say oh I see there was uh trap
Traders up here and that caused the
sell-off well no I mean you're not
talking about thousands and thousands of
Traders being stuck up here you know
realistically you know you probably this
is gold this is a one minute chart
um you know there's probably 30
contracts 30 contracts that were bought
up here near this high and this 30
contracts isn't enough to stop the move
and reverse it all the way down to you
know to new lows are much lower because
30 contracts that could easily be traded
within the next 30 seconds but you know
again I see that all the time if you're
looking at say you know crude oil
right people say oh you know you got
trap Traders down here okay and it
causes big move back up well no probably
not
um you know it's just one of those terms
that it sounds sexy and nice but uh in
in reality
for me at least there's certain ways to
identify trap Traders and I'll get into
that here so gold okay so let's just
sort of go back you know
to that high that was made here right
again you see you got that big wig up
you know people sort of associate big
Wicks with trap Traders you know yeah
it's kind of it's a probe going up you
can see even here it's got unfinished
auction up here but it's nine it's 36
it's 35
um and nine so you know about 70
about 80 contracts trade on the offer up
here you know up here on the on the bid
side you got the 60
what is that
um 44 54 64 65 66. so you know it's
pretty evenly distributed a little bit
more on the offer
than
on the bid but that's to be expected as
you're going into new highs right you
need that aggressive buying that to me
this isn't trap Traders what to me is
trap Traders is this one down here
this selling a balance why because again
it's probably not a trap Trader it's
probably a stop that got triggered at 52
because remember we had just made a high
earlier in the day up here at 58.90 sold
off again we got down to 54. over here
we got down to 54.30 and then we break
down below 52. and it comes down here
you see 52 contracts 36 contracts 29 22
zero zero zero and one on the offer side
so to me that's probably a stop that got
triggered I don't necessarily think it's
a big order that uh went through
other than a stop order okay I mean I
don't think someone just came in and
after the market sold off eight bucks
said sell me
200 contracts right now right it's
probably a stop that was sitting down
here at 52 and triggered it in a
snapback right away
so this
um you know again what is that 52 it's
about 90 contracts
um plus 30 it's 120.
plus 20 by 140 contracts okay got sold
down here
but then you look at the volume 140
contracts out of a bar that trades 981.
again if these Traders are trapped right
if everyone the whole thing of oh we got
a bunch of trap Traders down here
well okay there's plenty of room for
them to cover it in this bar and volume
wise or even the next bar volume wise
all right so then you can see how this
Market sort of went up came back down
then snap back up but really what I'm
looking at is sort of the footprint
that's left
um
call it a stop run if you want
52 you know this volume here with the no
counter trade sort of the you get this
imbalance coming in at the low after a
move
it's probably a stop a stop run more
than trap Traders but really what you
want to be watching is because again
it's a stacked imbalance
well where do you want to Stack
imbalance coming in right you want to
come in after a big move down has been
made or somewhere a little bit higher
right here you got a stack selling and
balance okay that's nice you got follow
through right in the next bar so it's
continuing here right this is sort of
why I think this is a stop more than
anything else
is okay you got that big push down it
gets triggered and then the neck then it
snaps right back right when there's a
big stop
the market often snaps right back right
which it did right came right back here
and it's trading above it so we got a
stack selling a balance but we're
trading above the stack selling a
balance
is that bullish or bearish well it's
it's bullish right even though it's a
stacked sound of bouncing by Nature
you're thinking of Stack selling a
balance should be bearish but the fact
that we're trading above it
actually sort of Uno reverse cards it if
you will
um because
what's telling you yeah you have some
Traders or a Trader that was trapped
most likely it was just a stop
protecting something that got triggered
here and then it snaps back up so
it's rejecting these prices down here I
mean the buyers down here
you know the people that work in those
bids down here if they were fresh bids
to get long you know they're sitting
pretty because the market starts
rallying back up to 56 right right up in
here but whenever I see a stack selling
a balance then immediately the next bar
is trading above it
I'm not thinking this Market is going to
continue selling off because I have a
stacked selling a balance
I should be trading below it like you
are over here not above it like here
okay now we see some heavier volumes
coming in here
um 114 103
okay so yeah there is some Supply coming
into the market at these levels
I want to see these are going to be
follow through is this Supply going to
be enough to sort of keep your foot on
the market all right and it's not right
you can see the market bounced up
came down here strong sellers at 5260
114 103 but then next bar we're trading
above it then we're just trading right
around it
okay and then it pops back up to new
highs or not new Highs but the the swing
highs take that back people so you
should swing highs no it's just swing
highs not new highs now crude oil today
again you know I'm just pointing out the
interesting things in the order flow
right to give you guys sort of a lesson
of what to look for and and how to use
it in your own trading now
a similar thing here in crude
okay but not in the sense of uh trap
Traders but when you're looking at heavy
volume you always want to be looking at
where it's coming in
okay and how it's coming in
so imagine right crude was selling off
11 35 made this low at 90 86.
coming down into low there's some
support right there's some decent bids
145 right 102 107.
and then it trades back up to 90 90. so
it makes that new low comes back in but
there's still some selling pressure in
here I can see the 181
okay so I know I got a big seller in
there and if you're watching this in
real time you can see that there's a big
seller in here right this bar it sort of
opens opens at this 92 area and there's
a big seller at 91.
so what do you want to watch you want to
watch are are we going to go down from
it
or not because is this pressure going to
be enough to sort of keep its foot on
the neck of the market well it's not it
Market just snaps right back up
right so you know it's one of those
things where when people think of trap
Traders right they're just looking at
these big Wicks and saying oh you know
someone came in and hit this down but
really
to me
one of the ways I'm going to look at is
where there's strong volume coming in
here right I got a fresh seller because
we just made this low we just traded
down there I got a fresh seller coming
in here with 181. this guy to me
these yeah if you're going to call
somebody trapped unfortunately
when you think of the term trap Traders
you're thinking in the in the smallest
sense of day trading activity but you
got to realize not everybody is trading
on the same time frame not every Trader
especially the big Traders trade on the
intraday time frame you know meaning
there's they're in and out big Traders
got long-term time frames that's what
makes them big Traders they're able to
hold positions longer so it's not like
oh yeah you know somebody came in here
is offering 181 the market starts
trading higher and they're scrambling to
buy it to get out
well no I mean the big seller if you're
a big institutional seller you're
selling it at 91 and then it rallies 10
ticks against you you gotta think oh my
God
I'm it's going against me I'm taking too
much heat I Gotta Get out no that's the
wrong mindset to have if you're trying
to think as an Institutional Trader if
you're an Institutional Trader you're
short at 1991
you know you're like well you know
if a rally is up 10 bucks okay then it's
then it's considered going against me
this is nothing to a big time you know
to a big institutional Trader a 10 cent
move 20 cent move 25 cent move that's
just that's to them that's Noise Okay so
again you know because I know a lot of
people you know they teach the whole
concept that trap Traders thinking oh
yeah the people are selling here at 181
they see it ticking up going against
them also they got to get out no if it's
a big institutional Trader
they don't give a they're just it's
10 ticks against them
okay but
coming back to the the concept that I
talked about yesterday previous support
or previous resistance becomes support
look at that you got the big volume
there right this is your resistance
record goes up comes right back down to
that level and then bounces okay that's
why I say you know
if you're looking at if you have a
footprint chart pay attention to where
these areas are coming in you know the
big volume levels right because
it could act as support or resistance
all right
um
let's go back here
what was it I think it was also in crude
today
I remember right
here this 415 okay this was about eight
just before 8 40 this morning markets
selling off healthy volume on this move
down 1500 1300 2500 1500. look at all
this negative Delta right very strong
right the the delta
final Deltas closing near our mid Deltas
you know it's pretty strong it's
consistent the Delta volumes are also
pretty consistent you know minus 28
Minus 15 minus 15 minus 28 Minus 15
minus 30 minus 16 minus 21. that's
strong selling right that's a sign of
strong selling I actually have the
Delta volume threshold change on this
one but let me change it back to sort of
the default
where is it here
yeah sit there 25 is sort of my normal
default
but when you see
the Delta lighting up magenta like this
for consecutive bars
it's a sign of strong selling okay and
remember our high was just made here
right at 8 12.
and then you're seeing the strong
selling come in minus 31 Delta volume
minus 37 minus 35 think it's here minus
magenta magenta magenta magenta magenta
so you know it's it's just
selling with impunity then it gets down
all the way down here
to 91 28. right
415 415 contracts
on the offer
trade
how do I know it's on the offer because
it's on the offer side people say well
how do you know that was an offer well
that's because the bid side is the left
side the offer side
is the right side okay so strong selling
all the way down finally you just you
know maybe this is as low as the guy
wants to go
okay down to 20 28.
then he's done
and I haven't talked about this right
when there's a big order in the market
and it's removed
whether it's a big order on the way up
or a big order on the way down once it's
finally filled
what do you expect the market to do do
you expect the market to keep going down
if it's a big seller and once the seller
is done no
it's probably if that seller is removed
from the market Mark is probably going
to bounce and it did it bounced up and
you can see it just right in that bar
itself made that reversal
and it came right down to that level
the seller's done he's not there anymore
right this is your sort of your last
resistance level on the way down because
again you can see Supply coming in on
the way down with some decent offers
coming in here you know this little
Bunch right here 108 124 153
um you know even a little bit earlier
the 145 in here
um you know sort of these pockets of
volume coming in on the offer and then
it gets down here and the guy is done
okay and it's going to be important to
watch
when the market comes back to it
is there any more selling there no it's
gone it's done
so if that selling is done then you're
going to end up with a bar like this
where it comes down test that to see if
there's any more selling
and there's not and what happens the
market rallies back up okay so that was
that level at 28. again then you had
that other level
um you finally got through but you don't
see big strong selling coming in here I
mean now but at this point it's just
sort of the market uh activity and then
again here the heavy volume the 181
coming in right
Market sold off
this is sort of the last of that selling
that needs to get done he's finished his
business
Market comes back down to that level
test it any more selling to do nope okay
Market rallies
up to here right then it came back down
down to new lows but at this point the
selling was done okay and again it's
nice to see crude I much rather see
crude on lows than on than on highs just
as a consumer
you know I got a suburban and I think
drinks uh
drinks gas sometimes it feels like but
uh yeah so anyway just pay attention to
those big volumes and watch you know
when you see it
market right a ninjatrader hit F6 that
will draw your line F6 draw your line
right you look under uh drawing tools
right here
F6 horizontal line but you just gotta
hit the F6 button okay
so anyway guys that's going to wrap up
this video on um you know sort of trap
Traders and heavy volume and
the misconception I know this video is a
little bit all over the place but anyway
you know I hope you can take
some of what I talked about today and uh
apply it to your own trading all right
everyone so I'll catch you guys on the
next video bye bye